all right we are now live for the ama
session for the day trying to get
everything set up I've got to be up here
in the upstairs area of our bedroom you
can see the bookshelves a little bit
obviously a lot of questions already
lined up for me I had to set up the mic
that I'll be putting down in just a sec
so doing a lot of multitasking right at
the moment so let me get the questions
up for myself and start tackling some of
them looks like we've already got quite
a few so William sonken Pynchon says how
has reading Kierkegaard and James
varieties of religious experience
influenced you as a Catholic since
they're so big on individualistic faiths
and not focused on dogma well I don't
think that you know a focus on dogma is
something peculiarly Catholic you know
and there's plenty of room for thinkers
who are engaging Kierkegaard or James or
any other similar people you know you
might think of you know could ask the
similar question to Gabriele Marcel you
know who also was was within that sort
of existentialist spectrum and tracks a
bit about Kierkegaard here and there I
don't know I kind of view it you know
I'm sort of Catholic in the lower case C
sense meaning I'm gonna take in
everything that I think is particularly
interesting and and worth studying and
engaging with which includes also people
like Hegel and Marx you know or
Nietzsche sort of like you know mock
Schaller was with with Nietzsche and
sort of like you don't think there's
like Thomas Aquinas and and Anselm or
with with their their predecessors and
interlocutors so I don't see that as
particularly problematic myself I
suppose for some people's understanding
of what Catholicism I mean anytime you
talk about Catholicism you start to lose
me anyway because it's
not really an ism it's a complicated
history and body of you know literature
some of which is biblical some of which
is is coming out of that and a bunch of
you know connections and then there's
something that is very difficult to wrap
your head around and define adequately
that we call a communion right along
with all sorts of other interconnected
things so for me it's kind of natural to
be looking for whatever anybody has to
bring to the table you know when it
comes to some of the things where James
is I would say conditioned by the the
social milieu that he's coming out and
rather dismissive of what the Papists
are Romanist might have to say I just
typically ignore that stuff is coming
from more ignorant or you know his
engagement with Catholics of his time
and an inadequate reading and say church
fathers or contemporary Catholic
literature I just sort of write that off
on that basis
all right Nicola asks I'd like to ask
you the starting question about
existentialism existence precedes
essence if you find time to explain it
well that's that's more sart's formula
than anybody else's starts I'll mention
this so Sartre was the kind of person
who without necessarily intending to
ended up cornering the market on the
term existentialism because once he came
out with that formulation and his
particular view on it in existentialism
as a humanism then other important
existentialist figures like you know
Martin Heidegger for example in the
letter concerning human or yeah was it
yeah the letter concerning humanism and
Gabrielle Marcel who'd previously been
one of the first people to use the word
existentialism and in French they
dissociated themselves from from that so
you know starts idea and I think that
you can see the
going through a lot of existentialist
thought is that first we exist that is
that we surged into being exists today
is not the same thing as SM and it's not
the same thing by the way in medieval
philosophy whether it's somebody like
Thomas where there's a strong you know
well worked out distinction between the
two or somebody like Ansem who uses the
term existed a different only that are
existing Mencia a sense and esse and all
that so the idea is that first we exist
first we live in a world first we
experience things and then we start to
try to make sense out of what it is that
we are as human beings and we are the
being according to Sartre for whom
existence precedes essence so other
things like for example this coffee cup
it has an essence so does the coffee so
does the light that that you know I'm
shining to have some sort of decent
lighting in here I'll see if I can get
it right there we go that's a little bit
better so is the microphone that I'm
recording on all of those things have
essences sort of my glasses before their
existence but human beings in a way
that's important for our self-identity
and thinking about the nature of human
potential exists before there's an
essence and we choose our essence so
that's sort of a thumbnail sketch of
that we can probably hit on that later
hold on just one second all right I just
gotta try to toggle something here so
okay let me think the next question Oh
chefs tough question chef Stefan is
Athens and Jerusalem says that Hegel's
philosophy entirely built on cons
practical reason where there is God
immortality of the soul and most
importantly free will is that true well
chef Stef is prone to hyperbolic
statements so anytime that you see chef
stuff making a very big claim you
we want to try to think is that actually
the case
did-did-did Hegel build entirely on
Kant's notion of practical reason no
Hegel is bringing in all sorts of other
elements you could say that Hegel is
just as Aristotelian as he is conscious
and going beyond both of them in that
respect as well but it you could
certainly say it's conditioned by it all
right
and it's uh you know he's working out
problematics of concha and practical
reason in the very section that we're
still and once I actually get myself
moving again on it working on in the
half hour Hegel project that is the
morality section he was discussing that
too by the way and we're talking about
the phenomenology in this case not like
philosophy of writer or the logic or any
of the other stuff but he also talked
about that in the the reason section
with you know reason discovering and
giving laws to itself as well but Hegel
is going beyond it and this actually
ties in quite well with the next
question which is about Kierkegaard and
his critique of Hegel I think something
that's important to remember when you're
reading existentialist thinkers like
here to guard or chest off or or some of
the other people like Nietzsche is
critical of Hegel at certain points is
that quite often what they're
criticizing is not Hegel as such but
Hegelian ism Hegel had become really one
of the dominant philosophical thinkers
and thereby approaches in his own time
not just in Germany but you know in
France and England I was catching on
there were st. Louis a galleons here in
in America making sense of the civil war
using Hegel caught on quite a bit in in
in Russia as well and you know
expositions of a great philosopher are
often not quite at the same level
they're often quite simplified they're
kind of dumb down and so I think a lot
of the Hegelian ISM of the time kind of
fits that that description
there are some elements of Hegel Hegel's
thought that Kierkegaard is going to
take very strong issue with and so his
chest off by the way chef's stuff did
not read Kierkegaard until I think the
nineteen nineteen 20s or 1930s and when
he did he recognized that what he was
finding in Tolstoy and Dostoevsky and
Nietzsche and just that check off and
people like that was also there in
Kierkegaard and you know chef stuff
himself said uh you know I recognize
heard with fellow traveler in this so
when they're criticizing Hegel part of
what they're criticizing is this
totalizing vision of things where
everything has to be understood in terms
of the universal rather than the
particular and there's there's a
definite movement a progress to history
and they were you know suspicious of
that so but Kierkegaard certainly holds
Hegel in high regard
um you know he says Hegel is as far as
philosophies gone you know Socrates in
ancient time to read the philosophical
fragments at Socrates who's being
another counter position to to you know
Christ you read fear and trembling and
it's Hegel right Hegel is not something
bad it's not like he's doing terrible
philosophy
it's just that philosophy understood in
that sense can only go so far so alright
let's see Jay RJ was--or your video on
becoming a philosophy professor was
great but I'm interested in what you
might suggest for interdisciplinary
students like me who need to make up for
lost ground well that's a good question
I mean to begin with I think if you
watched how to you know the video about
becoming a philosophy professor which I
shot you know quite a long time ago you
should have come away with the
impression that if you are able to
become a philosophy professor a lot of
is really up to luck and being in the
right place at the right time and not I
mean you can you can prepare it's sort
of a it's not even really a necessary
condition because there are a lot of
duds out there who just went to Ivy
League schools and got you know
positions and and our sort of
placeholders where other people ought to
be but you can certainly do better for
yourself by like you know working on
some you know areas that you know are
gonna be marketable in the job market
like applied ethics or something like
that and you know you should develop a
broad background we can go in and on
this for quite a while but even if you
do that there's no guarantee you're
gonna find a job other than like adjunct
work which you can't sustain for for an
entire career because you it's not a
livable lifestyle right so you know
you're asking well what do you do to
make up for lost grown you got to study
the stuff that that you ideally would
have been able to study as a BA or as an
MA
which means in my view I'm not just
trying to master you know the
cutting-edge stuff because that's kind
of faddish I mean right now people are
constantly asking me questions about to
lose well you know I find interesting I
don't like his stuff with guitar II
quite as much as I like his stuff on his
own but I'm willing to bet that 10 years
from now we're going through like a
Deleuze phase right now I bet you people
are not going to be as interested in him
10 years from now if it was like 10
years ago people are much more
interested in loving us and dairy dad
and they're not quite as interested in
that now so I would concentrate on you
know sort of key movements key thinkers
key schools in history of philosophy and
you don't have to master them but you
certainly want to know about them you
know like what what Plato actually
taught and then maybe a little bit about
some of the later plate mists what it is
that Aristotle had to say about things
it's not like you have to read every
single thing the guy wrote but it sure
wouldn't hurt to know the nick and mckay
and ethics I'll give you a funny example
I was at a dissertation defense the
other day and I wrote about this
little bit I think in our exes Deana @tk
my main author blog I was at a
dissertation defense and the chair of
the committee asked the you know defense
see the person defending his
dissertation a question pretty
straightforward question about virtue
ethics and Aristotle and pleasure and
the Oscar and the ASCII neither of them
had a good answer to it but if they had
read Aristotle recently just nikka
McKean ethics books 3 and 4 there would
have been an answer right there to their
little conundrum and of course I didn't
say anything because I was in the middle
you know I'm a guest at the thing but
you know if you actually know your
ancient philosophy know some medieval
philosophy know some of the high points
of modern philosophy I think that puts
you in a good position particularly when
it comes to as you're saying making up
for lost ground um
hungry American hi professor do you
think Freud is or should be relevant in
philosophy should it be taken more
seriously
great question yes and no I was just
reading civilization and its discontents
again yesterday and you know it's always
pleasant to read Freud in part because
he is a great essayist and he has a lot
of interesting points to contribute that
go beyond Freudianism for philosophy
yeah he definitely deserves to be read
and then he'll come out with something
where you're like oh my god I can't
believe that people actually took this
crap seriously like the Oedipus complex
for example you know you know and by the
way somebody like like huh will say oh
the Oedipus complex just one
configuration among many other
possibilities not something you find
universally in all cultures you know
whereas Freud was was insisting on that
and so where a lot of the Freudians of
the time in that case it was it was you
know his theory of the stages and you
know stuff about sexuality and and you
know you're like oh come on Freud so
there's there's the aspects of
Freudianism where it presented itself is
being truly scientific
and it dominated the the psychological
Academy and even you know some
philosophical stuff for quite a while
and that was sort of like a you know
buying into a dogmatic system and that
stuff most of it probably needs to be
rejected that said the notion that you
know things that we experienced in our
childhood could have an incredibly
important bearing upon our inner psychic
life and you know traumas that we
encounter maybe we need to uncover them
and work them through that's a brilliant
idea you know it's not unique to Freud
but some of the stuff that he says
supplemented by it by later thinkers
could be quite useful so you know and
and and some of his sort of theory of
human nature I think is quite cool and
it's worth definitely worth teaching
right
can you bring together Freud
productively with some of the other her
minuttes of suspicions like Mark ooza
does with you know for example Freud and
Marx yeah you can do that sometimes it
generates stuff that's not particularly
on point but but is interesting
nonetheless so you know and you think
about the wide range of stuff and
philosophy and a lot of what passes for
a contemporary continental or analytic
philosophy and you're like man
three-quarters of this stuff is pretty
hokey crap you know why not left Freud
hit there right so yeah he should be
taken seriously I I think you should be
taken seriously not in the sense that we
should be like you know Herman oods
poring over Freudian texts to try to get
out every single nugget of information
but I think he he deserves to be part of
the conversation Zorba asks how to get
over unrequited love philosophically
since the girl doesn't like me because
she thinks she's above my league well
there you've got half of the answer in
your very question right you know that
it's going to be unrequited you know
that unless you you believe that like
she is the only person for you ever it's
possible for you to feel this
effectivity towards somebody else why
not take a break from that and you know
try not to think about her and and and
do something else that's kind of
productive with with your time in your
life and pretty soon you're gonna find
you're gonna run into somebody else who
similarly trips your trigger and then
you can hopefully have it not be
unrequited and you can you know fine
find some person that potentially you
could date because they don't think
they're there above your league you
might also think about to you know what
do we want to be count as being above or
below
somebody's league you know we measure
people in terms of like 1 through 10 you
know what factors go in there you know
if somebody really is working on this
rating scale I don't know that there's
somebody worth dating anyway right but
you know there's there's different
approaches that you can take but I think
one of them would be thinking about you
know what is what is going to actually
make you happy now the ancient
philosophers and them and the medievals
and the moderns they all knew that this
this desire that we we call love can
certainly be incredibly strong and it's
not like you can just stuff it down and
repress it but you don't have to you
don't have to give in to it and
understanding how the emotions work and
understanding that it doesn't have to
drive you in this way even though that
it feels like it does that can often be
quite liberating all right
you'll Sullivan factor trying to study
German with an eye on reading
philosophical texts can you recommend
any books novels treatises short stories
to read early on that's a good question
I mean somebody who I enjoy quite a bit
who you know you might find interesting
you'll probably need a like a lexicon to
look up some words from time to time
would be you know Kafka's short stories
right
quite philosophically informed some
really cool themes being raised in them
so you know he would be good he's
readable don't try to read
somebody like Heidegger or Hegel you
know right a bat because tough to read
even in the original German cuz you know
in Heidegger's case he's playing around
with language and Hazel's cases terrible
stylist although he's a great thinker
it's just not not the clearest writer
somebody who is quite fun to read but
will require you to look up quite a few
words because he's got a vast vocabulary
of course Nietzsche Nietzsche makes up a
few words as well here and there you
know embarrassing to the defensive yeah
you know the transvaluation of values
ubermensch of course right you know made
up term but you know you can you can
puzzle your way through it you know I
would I would actually get yourself a
copy of the Grimm's fairy tales they're
they're fun as hell to read and and not
too difficult I think and there's a lot
of really interesting stuff going on in
them so you know if you start out with
stuff like that that would be quite good
I'm not somebody who really approached
my languages in a systematic fashion as
many people do so I don't know that I
have a lot of good advice to give about
that so alright william asks how does
your book on anger coming along very
very very slowly how is every book
crutch like that i've got coming along
very slowly this last academic year I
taught five classes each semester along
with having my usual load of clients and
consulting gigs and talks and stuff like
that so I really have not gotten that
much done but I'm making a little bit of
progress here and there this summer I'm
teaching two more online classes one of
which is starting in a couple days the
other which is starting in early July so
that's gonna keep me kind of busy
developing all this stuff for that
that's for Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design and teaching and
existentialism class and Marquette
University I'm teaching a business
ethics class but I'm you know I'm
plowing away at it
bit by bit by bit by bit so it's gonna
be it's gonna be quite a while pero pero
Botts young thoughts on William James
will to believe it's a great essay I
actually taught it a a couple weeks ago
again for my Milwaukee Area Technical
College intro to philosophy class I
really enjoy it the students usually
seem you know once they get past the
verbiage which is always a difficulty
for philosophy they really seem to enjoy
it you know I use examples like dating
you know how do you know if you don't go
on a date with somebody whether there's
somebody you really want to be with you
know you need to actually sometimes do
something in order to figure things out
same thing goes by the way unfortunately
for jobs for academic institutions you
know the students can totally relate to
this I say like you know did you did you
ever get like the you know brochures
about you know what this campus is gonna
be like and take a tour and all that
that's presenting some truth claims
right at least implicitly about what a
great college experience you're gonna
have is it really like that how would
you know well you could like ask people
who have been there and they might be
able to give you some insight but
oftentimes you yet you actually gotta
like you know go there and then you know
it's kind of too late and it's that way
for you know a lot of religious
experience you know I'll tell you one
thing about like it's something I did in
the past I'd like to get back into again
but I haven't done for a while when I
was really doing a lot of work on Saint
Anselm of Canterbury the great you know
12th century 11th century - writer I
started praying and I never really did
it well but I started what we call
praying the Liturgy of the hours and
much of what you're doing there is
reciting Psalms and other readings and
things like that and you can call it
praying or you can call it reading
and this is something that the you know
sprang up in the the church and you know
by the time that Ansem was doing it is a
well-established
sort of practice daily practice that
goes on today if you hear about people
like going to Vespers or you know going
to comp line or things like that that's
that's what they're talking about and
you know when I go to Saint Anselm
College and Abbey I actually do the
Liturgy of the hours with the monks and
I you know I wanted to see well what was
it like what sort of effects with this
hand on a person the only way to figure
that out other than reading other
people's accounts like in James you know
variety or the religious experience is
to actually do it and not to do it in a
sort of standoffish like this is all
[ __ ] but let me try it out kind of
way but it's actually like you know be
open minded and give it a shot and I
found it was quite good for me it it was
always a challenge to fit it into my day
I'm not a good person with time
management but that's you know that's an
example of the sort of thing that James
himself doesn't talk about but could
have talked about all right let's see
Adam t2r asks what are the weaknesses
and limitations of analytic philosophy
and how do I argue with them
I spend very little time actually
engaging with analytic philosophy
especially contemporary stuff because I
you know my time is extraordinarily
limited many of the weaknesses you have
to do with them not actually having much
of a basis in the history of philosophy
they they tend to read very shallowly
and and just like instead of like
picking up a whole book and reading it
all the way through like for example
right here here's you know McIntyre's
after virtue right they would be like
well let me just skip ahead to where the
argument is in Chapter here we go and in
chapter 14 the nature of the virtues
know you got a remove already got to
read the rest of the book right because
MacIntyre himself
analytic philosophy very very well came
out of that that tradition in part is
it's not like the other pages are just
like extra stuff that he threw in there
is sort of like an appendix it's
supposed to be there you know other
books okay there's the unconscious where
by the way MacIntyre going back to the
Freud thing MacIntyre thinks Freud is
well worth worth talking about when I
was in the seminar with him the faculty
seminar where I got to meet him and
interact with him daily it was a
rational choice theory Aristotelian
Thomism and Freud and Lacan that we were
studying because he definitely thought
Freud and Lacan were well worth engaging
with he talks about that a little bit
mostly in terms of Winnicott and of
course his dependent rational animals so
analytic philosophers going back to that
they're usually pretty poor about like
when they do anything that's engaging
history of philosophy they only engage a
little bit of it when they when they
stop doing that and they start really
engaging it like say Robert Brandon with
Conte and Hegel they quit being analytic
philosophers and they become much more
historians of philosophy I noticed they
often tend to be rather faddish we're
now in a phase that you can call post
analytic philosophy where they you know
they've split into a whole bunch of
different subject areas most of which
are not actually communicating with each
other but they have a common approach of
like let's go let's chart out what the
argument is what the assumptions are
let's try to make things as clear as
possible and it's a style of doing
philosophy but that's it it's a style of
doing philosophy they're sort of you
know stance of I just don't know don't
understand what these other people are
doing is is you know it's hard to take
seriously you're like either you're
posturing or you're just lazy and you
haven't read the texts and put put in
the time that said you know there's a
lot of continental blathering I would
say 3/4 of the continental philosophy I
run across in articles is unreadable
garbage but you know that's that's just
the way it goes you know
anonymous asks I would like to hear your
thoughts about how schooling is done are
you aware of how parts of the Prussian
education system made its way into how
schools operates it was designed to make
good submissive citizens to do whatever
they're told to do and are your thoughts
about that well I think we're so far
away from that to begin with here in
America we do not have a school system
you know other countries can you can
talk about an educational system because
they're much more national you know
centralized than we are here in America
with education with health care with
prisons with policing we have an
incredibly localized set of system so we
have a federal system up on top right
and that trickles down into other things
and that federal system includes the
government but it also includes big
people like Bill Gates and Melinda Gates
you know pumping tons of money into
common core things like that right and
then you have you know your theorists
who also have sort of a national extent
as well then you have all of the stuff
at the state levels we have 50 states
every single state is different from the
other education priorities very
education funding varies what they're
doing with education a very is
considerably from state to state
then we local the county level right and
each county has its own little animal
like here in Milwaukee County this is a
very different place than Eau Claire
County across the state very different
needs very different ideas and then we
have even lower than that we'll have
like the school system and so the school
system in the same county is not the
same thing we have you know here in
Milwaukee County we have the Milwaukee
Public Schools and they're different you
know there's like the main schools and
there's the charter schools right and
then every other municipality has its
own school system and people often move
to be in a different school system
because they're doing things differently
and to that the fact that we have
religious schools right and we have
other private schools you know I went to
for example um for middle school I went
to a private school that was not
religiously affiliated this makes it
impossible to generalize across
the board about the American system I
don't think there's much of that like
we're trying to produce nice worker
drones actually going on if there is
it's not to produce worker drones for
the state but rather for you know
corporate contexts so you know that
that's pretty much all I guess I have to
say about that Anonymous has another
question do I get bored doing AMAs do
you securely mock us to your colleagues
because of the questions we ask what are
your overall thoughts about these am i
know i like doing AMAs I like I like
answering questions I mean if you've
been following me for any time you know
that I actually mock my colleagues an
awful lot and I mock the sort of
traditional way of doing college
education I you know I was I was always
kind of a insider outsider even when I
was a traditional academic I thought the
way things were done was mostly [ __ ]
and many of my colleagues are kind of
you know placeholders who you know we're
much more about prestige than about the
actual texts and thinkers and and about
teaching and learning though I think
this is a really important way to to do
philosophy if I had the time and maybe
I'd do more of these well we'll see down
the line you know again I mentioned time
management is a big problem for me if I
succeed maybe I'll do more events kind
of like this sometimes I'll use
questions that come up as starting
points for doing some writing I can in
my author blog or exes do you know a TK
but no I don't I don't I don't make fun
of of people sometimes I'll use
questions that come up though with my
students and I'll be like here here's
the thing that like I'll do that with
this like AMA sessions with what's going
on on Twitter what what comes up on
Facebook and I'll be like here's here's
something that's somebody had to say
let's talk about this and students like
that you know because then they can see
that people are actually out there
talking about philosophy in the real
world you know
uh William asks another question can I
get by with just reading two curts
meditations Humes inquiry Hume has two
inquiries by the way Khan's first
critique and Hegel's phenomenology is
that two bare bones get by with what I
mean get by with claiming that you've
checked off a bunch of boxes I guess but
if the goal is to like understand
philosophy where's all your ancient and
medieval stuff and and why you know the
Kurtz meditations Humes inquiry why
Kant's first critique why not his second
critique which is a lot more accessible
and probably has a lot more to do with
with your life and then jumping into
Hegel's phenomenology I mean this is not
a I don't think that's a viable course
for studies what I would do you know
actually if you think this out what I
would do before trying to go into
anything like Hegel or even Khan's first
critique you know read some stuff in
ancient philosophies some of the classic
stuff some medieval stuff some early
modern stuff and before you're gonna
read the first critique read the
prologue oh man out to any future
metaphysics and then you know if you're
gonna read the first critique go ahead
and read it but don't expect to get that
much out of it you're probably gonna get
more out of Kant's practical philosophy
than his theoretical philosophy and if
you want to take on Hegel go ahead I
wouldn't start you know if I was gonna
say where to start with Hegel it
wouldn't be the phenomenology I would
say read his lectures on the history of
philosophy because then you've got some
like hallmarks of people that you know
and you can get what Hegel's kind of
stick is and his approach to them and
his lectures on the philosophy of
history and then maybe read that short
piece reason in history and then do the
phenomenology you know all right let's
see who else we got got a lot of
questions here
I just scrolled down on for a second
let's see here uh three by four
architecture any chance you'd do some
lectures on the early Heidegger thanks
for your ongoing work I did lectures on
the early Heidegger did lectures on
being in time that's really Heidegger
you know that's what's really Heidegger
as you can get that's like his master
early work yeah I'll do all their stuff
too it's a matter of finding the time
that's that's always the biggest problem
for me is carving out the time to get
things done but yeah so and what what
else the lectures Heidegger is well I
mean what is metaphysics that's early
Heidi or the other stuff that I have
available like in core concepts was that
stuff on the Plato's allegory the cave
that's actually later
Heidegger stuff but you know I'll get to
some some other early stuff but right
now I got a crank out a lot of stuff on
existentialism other existentialist
authors this this summer for this class
uh Adam teach or what are they adequate
philosophical views on language well
there's a lot of adequate philosophical
views on language so I don't know
exactly what what you're asking about
there Jack 'epic thoughts on Vidkun
shine nice segue there
the Kingstown is an interesting guy I
think his conception of language game
quite quite useful I don't think it's
absolutely unique I think other people
were coming up with similar things in
the 19th century and even even Bishop
Berkeley was you know noting that there
were many different uses of language in
his principles right but what else other
Anna quit use on language I mean you
know you might actually start if you
want to look at language you might start
earlier on and kind of work your way
backwards somebody who I think is
particularly good is Umberto Eco he's
got this book semiotic sin the
philosophy of language that's a great
place to like get a lot of references
for who you want to go back to and read
so that that could be kind of fun bit
constraint going back to the Vick
constrain thing so Vick and Stein I've
mentioned this before
thinking's kind of a missed opportunity
I wish he'd read more widely in the
history of philosophy because I think
his work would have been much much
better in that case
Sisyphus have you read anything by gee
Jack what do you think about his views
on Hegel you Jack ISM all over the map
kind of guy i jus Chuck is somebody who
I find interesting but I also find
annoying quite often because I'm like
you know I like when he buckles down in
his fairly systematic about stuff that's
the stuff I like to read like his when
he was doing early work on you know
really in in semiotics some of the early
stuff that was that was quite good at
bringing in desire bringing these
authors I also like reading ggx op-ed
pieces by the way I don't read his books
very often anymore because I don't get
that much out of it I you know let me
put it to you this way if your goal is
to understand Hegel read Hegel don't
worry about like what secondary
literature what you know cutting-edge
exponent you should embrace get the
Hegel down first and then start reading
other people and you can say oh yeah
yeah I think they got this right oh
that's really insightful I didn't see
that before in there that's when you
want to go to people like gee Jack um
Adam what ideas if Reagan were rejected
by his successors analytic philosophers
it depends on which analytic philosopher
you're asking about it's not like Anna
like philosophy was one coherent school
not everybody bought into is you know
sense and reference thing some people
did some people didn't
I mean Vik and Stein criticizes frag at
certain points himself so in those later
works but I don't know enough about that
Pro hem have you seen Arthur Holmes
videos on YouTube I have not i don't
watch many other people's YouTube stuff
because I don't know the time Chuck
Norris could you explain the difference
in nuances between endurance and courage
in the stoic sense Socrates was said to
unite his endurance by spending nights
outside so courage is one of the four
virtues right and each one of the four
virtues if you read arias didymus or dad
his lair to base or Cicero some of the
other thinkers think of it as a basket
in which there's a whole bunch of sub
virtues endurance cartina is one of
those sub perches and I'm so that that's
it it's sort of a part to whole
relationship uh and ooh first how fast
you read you think that speed reading is
any useful especially in philosophy I
don't know how fast I read it I read at
the rate that the book requires you know
and a lot of my reading these days is
rereading which is different than
originally reading I will answer the
thing about speed reading I think that
speed reading is for idiots you know
it's useful for technical documents it's
used for like business tax or stuff like
that it's useful for newspapers if you
want to read literature you want to read
philosophy you want to read any sort of
important theory speed reading is for
bros who want to like impress people
with how much they've gone through
because you asked him afterwards about
anything that's actually important in
the work and they don't know a damn
thing you know don't skim don't speed
read if you're gonna read philosophy
read philosophy if you know I've gotten
each's left if this takes you two weeks
to get through then it takes to two
weeks to get through it because that's
what it takes a book is you know the
author engaging you the reader by means
of language with these great ideas and
experiences and stuff like that and you
probably should be prepared to reread
you know when you're really reading
philosophy it's not like this it's not
like okay this page now this page now
this page now this page
it's more like okay this page wait what
the hell is that
I gotta go back here and check this out
now oh oh I see how they're connected
okay let me figure out where I was I'm
getting the context you know it's it's
not a linear sort of thing and for the
most case so alright program how much do
you think we should take from the
pre-socratics like Heraclitus we have no
books remaining it's difficult to know
anything they thought for sure I mean
what should we take we should take what
we've got which is not much right I mean
there were Herrick Lydians and antiquity
if anybody was gonna claim to be a
Herrick Liddy and today I'd just say
that sounds like [ __ ] to me
you know I don't know what you're
talking about and you probably don't
know what you're talking about either or
somebody was gonna claim to be a parma
Didion you know or even a Pythagorean
well though with the pythagorean's we do
have neo Pythagorean texts right so
those you could you could talk about all
right Luke LAN any thoughts on ernst
kassir he also talks a lot about
language differently than Vidkun Stein
or Heidegger yeah kassir is an
interesting guy haven't read him for a
long time
he is that I read but it's been too long
for me to speculate about about it I
mean it's not as if it can stand in
Heidegger are the only people you can
you can go to or we're fortunate in that
we have a wealth of people talking about
language you know including people that
we don't usually associate with
philosophy of language Hegel talks a lot
about language in the phenomenology in
certain points right you know the the
medievals often had a lot to say about
language a lot more than we usually we
usually see you know so alright let's
see what else we got here
Abdul says in 1972 Lester Bangs wrote
that Black Sabbath is the first truly
Catholic rock group or the first group
to completely immerse themselves in the
fall and redemption do you agree with
that how take that is a really
interesting idea
I mean geezer butler was a Catholic well
is a Catholic he's still alive I don't
know how often he practices but it
really did have a he's the one who wrote
most of the lyrics too by the way
so yeah you know I guess there's a lot
of people so I'm gonna go on a bit of a
sort of free association might be rant
here there's a lot of people when it
comes to Christianity and metal I'm the
only going to talk about metal because I
don't know enough about other rock
genres to be you know helpful with that
you know there is this tendency to like
see themes about the occult and
sexuality and partying and be like this
stuff is you know satanic this stuff is
deliberately you know hedonistic against
against religion it kind of depends on
how you understand your religion if your
religion is vast enough like you know
that of say Chesterton or or Lewis or
Graham Greene to encompass the human
condition as such then I think the dark
parts of the human condition have to be
explored you know I mean think about
like so I'm wearing Judas Priest British
steel right here right and the whole you
know metal aesthetic of the motorcycle
stuff it was it didn't only come out of
Judas Priest but but Rob Halford played
a big role and it turns out that came
from you know BDSM stuff and his you
know the gay subculture that he was
participate again you know is that
anything that could be embraced or
rethought or examined you know
assimilated or do we have to like push
that off there's all terrible bad stuff
I think there's a lot of a lot of
religious people who just do that you
know but I think that there's possible
and then there's another thing too we
you know we say well we can we can adopt
this but for good you know I'm gonna get
bands like striper
and all these Christian metal things and
you know even the genre of white metal
none of which I give a [ __ ] about at all
you know I find that stuff really boring
for the most part because it's sort of
like we're gonna take this thing that's
really vital and has
all this potential and then we're gonna
superimpose this this you know safe
doctrinal thing on top of it and that'll
that'll be good
another possibility is you you enter in
judiciously and you say wow holy [ __ ]
there's something going on here and this
is really interesting how much of this
can we understand can we make sense out
of where do we have to draw lines you
know so that you know that that's a
viable take I think Austin asks what do
you think what do you do about being
around people that don't have any
reverence for philosophy and how do you
put philosophy to practice in those
environments well you do philosophy
without telling the people you're doing
philosophy so like when I work with
corporate clients and I'm doing stuff
about say anger management I don't tell
them that most of what I'm drawing upon
is coming from Aristotle the Stoics
Thomas Aquinas and a few other places
right they don't need to know that until
they start getting interested and then
I'll be like oh hey by the way here's
the bibliography you want to know more
about this here's what you might
actually read because you know most of
the time they're gonna be like I had a
philosophy class it's sake I don't wanna
I don't want to be involved with that
sort of thing
so that's part of you smuggle it in you
know I mean the good news is is that
whatever is being done in organizational
theory or business theory or
communications or education or training
and stuff like that is usually such
watered-down crap that when you bring in
some philosophical concepts it's almost
always better than what they're working
with you know so you've got a bit of an
advantage and you know you you apply
some of the things you learn in
philosophy like making distinctions
really well without telling people that
that's your doing that because you're a
philosopher until they ask right so I
think that's part of how you do it
as most of the videos they've seen from
you are on ethics or psychology do you
have an interest in metaphysics yeah and
if you've been watching the channel I
did stuff on Aristotle's metaphysics
just a couple months ago you know I have
an interest in metaphysics in the broad
sense I would say that that psychology
ethics and metaphysics all connect up
with each other in a large degree and
you know I would say that the biggest
thing that I do have stuff on is it
unethical
my ethics classes and every time I teach
an intro class ethical stuff is a big
part of what I what I'm teaching so I
think if you look a little bit more
broadly at the the videos that I have
out there you'll see you know stuff on
the will that's metaphysics it's not
just psychology stuff on whether God
exists or not you know that's that's
metaphysics as well a philosophy of
religion is kind of a sub-branch for the
most part of metaphysics and rico any
philosophical view on how to avoid
procrastination and be a productive
person well there's no magic bullet for
that being able to identify
procrastination when you're doing it
being honest with yourself I'd say is
the first step and then you know you
know looking at things teleologically
can be helpful understanding you know so
understanding what what what you really
want and and what's needed to get it the
means and the ends that can it's not
gonna like make you not procrastinate
but you have to remind yourself of that
at different points you're like listen I
really want to be able to like have a
book someday I need to actually do some
writing writing is one of those
activities where it's really easy to
procrastinate you're like you know the
bathroom could use a cleaning I better
get to that Oh what about cooking
something for the week you know it like
any let's do some research and you go
down the rabbit hole you you have to
remind yourself of what your end is and
what the means are to get it
what will interfere
with the means yourself away from the
considerations like well if I just do
this other thing this is also a means to
the end like now no that's not it
another thing is to you know remind
yourself if you if you're
procrastinating it's probably stemming
from a habit and do you want to
strengthen the habit or do you want to
weak in the habit and make yourself
better off the next time that you're
you're dealing with this stuff bye bye I
don't know like you know taking a stand
at this point the other thing is
oftentimes procrastination goes along
with another P which is perfectionism if
it can't be done perfectly I'll do it
tomorrow
you know I won't i won't work on it
today and so just remind yourself that
you can get partial work done on
something and it's better to get
something done than then nothing alright
Tom ate by what criterion to judge if
what a philosopher says is true by
argument but then what intuition logic
isn't it just an aesthetic choice
especially when it comes to metaphysical
questions well there's no one single
thing right we have to be pluralists
when it comes to criteria for truth and
you put them together and you work at it
for a long time and sometimes it turns
out that you're wrong about it you
revise it sounds kind of like you're
looking for like what's the one thing
that I can totally depend on and there
there isn't anything like that generally
where were you no I mean you could say
that it has aesthetic elements to it you
know that's definitely the case is it
just a purely aesthetic choice I don't
think so unless you know unless you're
somebody who's like an aesthete you know
and there are some out there so yeah
sonís I live in Athens is this your
stoic on too difficult for someone not a
well acquainted with stoicism to
understand good question it's the
opposite of that stoic Han is not this
is not an academic conference for
academics to get together and talk about
you know what exactly are the
indifference or anything like that this
is a popular
philosophy thing meant to introduce
people to stoic ideas and practices and
be a way for them to network and talk
with each other and do workshops that's
the way they've always been if you you
know just look at the the lists of the
stoic on stuff that's out there or I
mean go to the modern stoicism video
channel and watch some of the talks that
are on there and you'll see the kind of
facts that people tend to be giving all
right kaya will you be doing anything on
Marx eventually I've already done stuff
on Marx you got to you got to check the
channel you you know use the search
function or just put in google sadler
marks video and you'll find a sequence
of five or six videos that I did on
marks some time ago for a class all
right
I'll be doing more eventually when I
have the time but that depends on the
time as a philosophy will as a
philosophy major I've come to lean more
towards misanthropy than I once was any
advice on how to deal with this or
should I continue riding this train
misanthropy is not a great way to go you
know it's so what is MIT's Anthropy
hatred of mankind you know sort of a
distrust of human beings and looking
down upon them disliking them you know
not wanting to engage with them I mean
there are some philosophical points of
view that will kind of steer you towards
that but that's not where the vast
tradition of philosophy is I mean you
read somebody like the carrot Descartes
was not a misanthropist you know or Hume
or Aristotle these were people who loved
other people and thought that human
beings are really interesting even
Thomas Hobbes you know you could say
he's very pessimistic about human beings
yeah but he also wants to fix things you
know and he's writing at a time of Civil
War by the way in his home country so
yeah
Gabriel do you think Hegel's theory of
conscious history points towards a truly
predictive notion of social history no
not at all you know III don't think that
Hagel had the market cornered on the end
of history at all so that's kind of a
non-starter
you know Dakota have you read Karl
Rahner so what do you think about his
work yeah we did an entire course on
spirit in the world I'm not that big on
rauner I never found him that that great
or insightful he's kind of popular among
liberal Catholic legends but I just
never really got into him so uh let's
see here
here's a here's a question by will as
someone interested in aesthetics why is
this branch of philosophy seen by some
as the odd one out neglected well I mean
in philosophy you pick any branch it's
seen by some as the odd one out
neglected there's some people who are
like even ethics doesn't matter you know
just metaphysics just you know logic
just this I don't think that aesthetics
is any more on the outs than metaphysics
is in some circles it's it's you know
it's not an area where there's a ton of
jobs unfortunately although you know I I
have the opportunity at Milwaukee
Institute of Art Design if I want to
design an ethics class or aesthetics
class I probably could I'm just not
unfortunately for that job I'm not a
specialist in aesthetics so we'll see if
I ever do that I also think aesthetics
is often taught outside of the
philosophical establishment but then a
lot of ethics is too you know a lot of
philosophy of communication and
philosophy of technology is alright
written will we be able to tip or donate
to your channel through crypto
currencies like Bitcoin sometime soon
I don't know that Bitcoin wallet I
suppose I could get one
but that would be something I'd have to
like set up and and you know I don't
know I probably in the future
I mean I have a friend who's very into
Bitcoin stuff and I could give him to
help me out with that I guess
Alexander Angela whiskey what are your
thoughts on Alan Watts I don't take him
that seriously I think he was sort of a
creature of his time the hippies and and
other New Agers these days are really
into him because of his spirituality but
it's all kind of you know the stuff that
I read back when I was in my teens and
20s I never found all that insightful
the people who are like from the
religious traditions that he talks about
often say he got this wrong he got this
wrong he got this wrong so he seems kind
of like a you know a guy who was really
keen on forming connections and was
really into like discovering new stuff
and wanted to share it but I don't think
that that there's any sort of lasting
great value to what he's doing I think a
hundred years from now everyone's gonna
be like Alan who just like we're like
what Herbert Spencer who is he you know
so you know it's kind of cool that he's
got stuff on YouTube that people can
watch but you know that's uh yeah that's
about it for him
let's see what just skipped a little bit
Andrew Davis do I have a particular
school of philosophy I subscribe to an
ism that I believe in such as
Aristotelian ism or existentialism yes I
have a whole bunch which means that in
strict sense I'm not I'm not any one of
them right I'm an eclectic I've
mentioned this a number of times I'm
sort of a Ciceronian eclectic which
means that I'm not just doing like you
know one from column a one from column B
mix it all up together and a stew and
there we go
it's rather that I study you know
schools and and movements pretty
extensively and I'm like this stuff over
here is pretty good but I'm not going to
buy into this part over here Cicero
himself call
himself an academic skeptic but he's the
kind of academic skepticism that he's
embracing is clearly eclectic and so I I
have a sort of similar thing I draw on
the plateless tradition of some things
the Aristotelians Stoics some Christian
thinkers some existentialist some
dialectical thinkers you know some
philosophy of language stuff what I find
useful I end up adopting and trying to
find ways to make fit and I can't say
that I've you know got some sort of like
comprehensive synthesis worked out you
know maybe maybe in my 50s that'll
happen I'm getting getting close you
know I'm gonna be 49 this year who knows
maybe that won't happen ever for me and
that's okay then I can be a pluralist
like William James you know we'll see
how it happens all right let's see here
some back and forth between some people
discussing stuff piggy Pig do I think
antinatalism is a good philosophy I
would say it's a good philosophy for
anti-natal lists you know it'd be cool
if they don't reproduce at all but no I
don't think a good philosophy you know
it's better not to be born and all
that's our stuff that's been talked
about for a very long time that's the
sort of thing that Nietzsche in in birth
of tragedy is already like you know
talking about this will to death and how
do we overcome that these three noble
responses the DNS see and a poly
paulownia and Socratic and I just don't
take it seriously I suppose I should
read some classic antenatal aslim
someday but I don't know why people keep
asking me about it you know is it
something that that that is getting some
real traction I also I suppose have to
check on that Chuck Norris how can one
who seeks to live holy s--t Oleg stoic
we find middle ground between adhering
and ambitions of career at cetera even
though value judgments are rewired is
the only option to abandon all ambition
well that would not be stoicism actually
that would be our East Oh
rather than xenos approach our East Oh
was you know a guy who was a follower of
Xena but got rid of everything else he
was it's like nothing other than virtue
matters at all
the Stoics recognized this entire range
of the indifference if you want to see
how Stoics makes sense of that read
Cicero's on the ends book three where
it's laid out pretty clearly or if you
want to read a really great contemporary
but rather difficult treatment of that
read Becker's a new stoicism you know
the the indifference do matter
they just don't matter for Stoics in the
same way as the good and the bad do
right their preferred and rejected
indifference so you know living holy
stoic lee would mean taking on that
thing the difference between the the
good and the bad virtue and vice and the
whole realm of the indifference I mean
epictetus also tells you as well know if
you're attempting to live holy stoic Lee
says this in the discourses that well
indifference themselves are neither good
or bad and are not really up to us in
any important way our use our crisis of
indifference is completely up to us and
is good and bad and does have to do with
prior races so yeah Johan asks I was
wondering about neo stoicism and the
idea of and uniting Catholicism and
stoicism what's your opinion on it
that's that's an area that I'd like to
get to spend more time on reading I've
only read bits and pieces of some of the
people that are like lip CIS and carand
and you know some of these other I'm
blanking on their names these other
thinkers that are trying to combine and
let's let's not call it Catholicism
what's called Christianity right they're
trying to combine stoicism and
Christianity there's a long you know
tradition of that what are the prospects
for it it really depends on the
individual I mean Pascal is really down
on them and he knew those guys
he thinks that that stoicism and he
particularly singles on Epictetus that
they're right in one sense they they
grasp the grandeur of human being but
they don't they don't also understand
the misery of human being so they're
missing out on something and they their
prescription for Humanity is not
something that could be universalized so
it's well worth looking into these
authors and their there are neo stoic
elements too like Rene de cartes ethics
that you see in the meditations like in
meditation for in his I mean he and
Princess Elizabeth they actually read
Senecas on the happy life or was it on
was it on another thing on benefits
maybe and they discussed it together
right so there there are some important
17th century thinkers who are looking
very closely at stoicism alright let's
see what else we got
I have no idea how this is supposed to
be pronounced oh la la la la la la was
the oedipal complex literal symbolic or
both I mean at best symbolic I guess but
like I said Lacan for example says you
know the oedipal complex Freud really
insisted on this but it's it's not
something Universal and I think the
oedipal complex you know you can say
that there you can observe dynamics
sometimes are these family tensions like
that but to universalize it into like a
metaphysical constant I think is kind of
kind of nonsense so you know I wouldn't
I wouldn't worry too much about it it's
not like it plays an important role in
psychology today made of clay what are
some philosophers you think are not well
known today but will be well known in
the future or is it impossible to say
that's a great question
not
all known today but will be well known
in the future I don't know it's it's so
difficult to speculate this isn't this
is a great question actually III I wish
this is something I should give more
thought to because you know you read
every back of a book blurb and they're
like this is amazing stuff and this is
gonna revolutionize this and that you
can read stuff from like the 70s about
you know people who are nonentities now
and you're like well I guess that didn't
happen right and you read stuff
contemporary you know works coming out
and you're like oh yeah that you know
these are people who are quite you know
prestigious for the moment right now and
then they're just gonna disappear once
again into you know like who who today
reads Victor Cruz Ana right nobody
except for a few scholars right
who even reads the Oscars I remember one
time going to the Carl yeah Spurs
Society meeting that spent one year
because I wanted to see well who was
actually interested in the Astor's these
five people that all knew each other and
struck me as being quite dull and I
never went back again but yeah Spurs at
one time was like a really major
significant name and in philosophy I
don't know that's very very difficult to
say
[Music]
Diogenes the cynic what do you make of
speculative realism I don't pay very
much attention to it
I've seen graham Harmon talk and what he
was saying was kind of interesting but
didn't strike me as being you know super
original or you know groundbreaking or
anything like that and I don't know the
other people involved in it well enough
to really say much about it so we'll see
if it has if it continues to have legs
or if it becomes a little you know
backwater with its own little society
and and stuff like that I was a little
disappointed actually meeting Harmon
unfortunately somebody who is interested
in Lovecraft as he is you know I thought
I thought I'd see more
Gambhir ik do I agree with Hegel's
criticism of shilling of shelling maybe
like in the phenomenology where he's
rejecting like intellectual intuition do
I agree with it yeah I don't I don't buy
into intellectual intuition but there's
there's not that much to to say about I
I you know actually there is something
to say about people ask me questions
about like mysticism as well unless you
can actually articulate something I'm
not very interested in it you know I I
don't want to hear about like the
ineffable or the thing that you just
have to have the experience of without
you know somebody describing it and so
you just got to do it man no I want to
hear a little bit of what the doing is
like and what you experience so I think
that's that's part of it um let me see
if I can make sense out of this question
from n so Leon I study philosophy at uni
I love it but I am afraid not to like
philosophy in the future of you ever
thought like this when you're a student
you're afraid that like your viewpoint
on philosophy is going to change and
you're not going to enjoy it any more
well I mean that could happen you
certainly will experience cases where
you were really into a philosopher or a
way of approaching things and then you
kind of grew out of it like I you know
I've gone through a lot of different
phases that I've done videos on and you
know where I was like super super super
into this and then I I got out of it but
that's not the same thing as like no
longer loving philosophy you get out of
it and go into something else you know
and it's okay to by the way to have
fallow periods where like you're you
does not enter reading philosophical
texts for a while
that'll happen at certain points in your
life you know your life is not just you
know being a student you've got all
these other aspects relationships you
know as you age new things come on the
scene you have to have a job
all right let's see what else we have
Damon reading Paul and the Stoics any
thoughts there read the comment similar
beliefs for similar categories I
unfortunately I had a it took out a copy
of Paul on the Stoics because we were
gonna discuss it me and one of my tutor
tutorial students and got recalled you
know he went to the Marquette library
and I had it and I was able to read the
introduction and then it got recalled
and of course if you don't turn in a
book they freeze your account and so I
had to like go back and give it back to
the library so I haven't read enough
about about it
trolls what is it the trolls burger guy
I don't remember the the author um let's
see here
ah then we get over the tension between
the right and the left and current times
and with regard to the current global
issues I don't know I don't think we
will unfortunately I think these are are
so much a part of our cultural system
it's not just about like economic you
know classes clashing with each other
it's it's so much a part of our cultural
system and at least here in America so
many people are investing so much of
their psychic energy and being on the
left or being on the right and you know
the other side being just complete
[ __ ] or morons or bastards or
whatever that it's I don't I don't see a
way we're gonna get past that unless we
have some sort of major catastrophe and
then then all bets are off right and
even then it might not not really
fix things Jakub what is the point of
presenting the philosophical ideas in
the republic in the form of dialogue and
myth well those are two totally
different things right dialogue why not
present things as dialogue dialogues are
a way of having you know a living
conversing
going on that you could jump into so
Plato does that for most of his works
and many other people wrote dialogues
Aristotle by the way wrote dialogues we
just don't have any of them and so did
so did quite a few other people you know
Cicero writes write some pretty great
dialogues Anselm of Canterbury writes
dialogues why not write philosophy in
the form of dialogues now myth is a bit
of a different thing why why have
mythological accounts in the middle of a
purportedly rational account well when
you see Plato bringing it it's usually
because we've exhausted the rationality
part now he's suggesting a possibility
they saying I heard the story from these
priests that XYZ maybe things are like
this and so you use the myth as kind of
a starting point for your thinking but
it's it's it's not you know it's a
possibility it's not something that he's
absolutely committing himself to
something that makes a good story which
is what mythos means anyway story all
right all right let's see Nick Bolen
what do I think of Walter Kaufman's take
on Nietzsche reading it between
Zarathustra and Beyond Good and Evil
I think Hoffman is an interesting
interlocutor to take into account I
would say I was I was back when I was
like in my early you know graduate years
I was much more influenced by Kaufman
than by other commentators is again in
this argument all the time with this
this guy who became a buddy of mine
because he had studied with Stanley Rose
and so of course he was and he was kind
of a follower type so he like bought
into Rosen's
take on Nietzsche hook line and sinker
and I'd kind of repose kind of a more
Kaufman esque
approach also you know one that was
coming out of the other people that I
was reading to like Louis Farrakhan
Saleem and I was I was very down on the
possibility of getting anything remotely
political out of Nietzsche so I was more
about like you know self transformation
and
I will say this you know there's a
tendency to try to especially have
people on the left to try to defang
Nietzsche or domesticate Nietzsche and
turn him into something that would be if
not necessarily you know no long you
know you you know you don't want a
Nietzsche who's actually like gonna be
harnessed by the anti-semites and the
fascist cuz he thought they were idiots
right and he says so quite clearly
another nationalist but you also don't
want a nature where it's all just about
metaphor and rhetoric and self-discovery
man or any sort of stuff like that
because there is you know there is a
hard edge in Nietzsche he does believe
in elites he does believe in in
exploitation and domination he does
think that we have a genealogy that we
can trace back that has cruelty at its
roots in so many places
um all right die are the ancient Greek
texts more valuable just because people
spend more time on them know the people
spend more time on them because they're
valuable because there's content there
and I don't know what you mean in
comparison to more valuable than what
more valuable than you know the
newspaper more valuable than texts from
other countries you'd have to you'd have
to specify what you mean they're nice
myst Ian could the question posed by
Augustine in the first page of the
confessions which is more important to
cry help from God or to know him be seen
as the position taken by Kierkegaard and
Hegel no Kierkegaard is interested in
knowing God
Hegel's interested in knowing God
they're both interested in like being
connected with the divine which you
could interpret his help why not look at
this in terms of you know the
development of Christian philosophy
where you got these two it sort of
Antipodes from each other but but both
part of the same you know broad current
of Lutheran developments of Christian
philosophy I will
I wouldn't try to schematize it quite in
that way a chromatic tone ilysm have I
gotten a spirit of trust yet I have not
and I'm not even sure what that is let's
take a look real quick Oh Brandon's book
now I have not done that I did get to go
to Brandon's Aquinas lecture where he
was talking quite a bit about how he's
you know how he's interpreting Hegel
that was a lot of fun so let me bring
this back up and I gotta since I shrank
this I got a close some of the account
or some of the tabs to read the stuff
from all of you there we go
let's see no name a good thing about
languages is just how many contact
points are possible you can immerse
yourself okay that's not a question yeah
Andrew says I've been binge watching
your videos I'm feeling down it wouldn't
say depressed but I'm not happy I can't
remember the last time I was any advice
that's a good question
I yeah I any advice I would say think
about you know the last times that you
were happy what what were you doing what
were you experiencing what was going on
and then you know try to not necessarily
recapture that but you know try to get
partial elements of that and you know
maybe start out with pretty small things
like you know on a cold rainy day like
the one I'm looking up at our skylight
right now that that you've got you know
make yourself a nice whatever it is you
like to drink and you know light a
couple candles and snuggle together with
if you've got a pet under a blanket and
read some decent stuff or watch a
challenging show or listen to some some
good music just you know
that can sometimes help to kick-start
things you could say like I you know I
like to listen to metal stuff but I also
like a quite a bit of classical stuff I
particularly like sati and Debussy and
you know Prokofiev and and a few other
Bach you know Bach was good for that
sort of thing as well and it's okay to
feel melancholy and happy at the same
time that's that's often natural for
some people all right astral act what is
your opinion on the to begin school of
played platonic studies attempts at
reconstruction of the unwritten doctrine
are you familiar with it vaguely I mean
I don't buy much about I don't I don't
buy the esoteric exoteric thing to begin
with I think that a lot of that is maybe
there could be something to it but it's
sort of like speculating about the
aliens on the other side of the Moon
you know nobody actually knows and you
got to make so many assumptions just to
get anything off the ground that it
usually ends up being kind of circular
and I'm not interested in I'm interested
in reading Plato thinking about what's
actually there in the text what I can
draw out of that same thing with any
other author I'm not interested in the
books that Nietzsche didn't write I'm
not interested in you know the books
that you know I don't pick whoever you
like the books that they were hinting at
at doing but never had a guy - so
Antarctica if you have any tips on
fighting nearby philosophical events
that's a great question - yeah use your
social media right Facebook if you set
your settings right we'll alert you to
events that are in your area right and
you can actually like do a search on
that there are all sorts of event sites
out there like a vent brighten event see
you know and they they will list things
as well look in your local you know city
or town
pages you know like we have here we have
on Milwaukee and the Shepard Express and
you know new walkie and stuff like that
and people like me put our events into
those pages when we have the time
meetup.com right as another thing you
can look on there when it comes to like
stoicism go to the stoic fellowship page
and see if there's a stoah near you
which there very well might be you know
there's a whole bunch of things that you
can do I would actually take your your
local city and just you know type your
city name philosophy and see what comes
up you should also like check out any
you know local universities or colleges
and get on their mailing lists for
philosophical events those those are all
things you could do alright um David
fusilli err do I think there would be a
value in a layperson working through
philosophical works and blogging their
thoughts I hesitate since I've never had
a in real life class and philosophy sure
I mean there's you know think about this
some of the great philosophers that we
studied didn't happen you know a class
in philosophy they studied it on their
own and then they wrote about it and
there's all sorts of really interesting
stuff being done by people who didn't
necessarily get to go to college and
study philosophy and even if you're
blogging and and not too many people are
reading it I mean not that many people
even read my author blog that's that's
okay you know you're sort of charting
out your own your own views on things
and working out your thoughts you might
get a little bit embarrassed about them
later but that's okay I mean I look back
on some of the papers that I wrote like
as an undergrad or graduate student I'm
like holy crap this is bad
yeah but that's okay that's part of that
that's part of the process right it's
not anything that you have to cover up
um silver shadow do have an experience
with or opinion of the B fill Oxford's
master program in philosophy no I mean
I'm pretty distrustful of elite
universities I think that they're mostly
about creating you know diplomas and
titles and stuff like that I would
actually have to look at the program and
who's involved in it and what they have
you do and stuff like that I think you
can get just as good of a philosophical
education at you know your local state
school as you can at Harvard or Oxford
or anything like that but much of that
is just prestige and unfortunately a lot
of that is slowly dissipating I mean
when I hear when I hear somebody brag
about London School of Economics or
Oxford or Cambridge or Harvard or Yale
or University of Chicago you know I
usually look at the person I'm like well
what are they done is is it stuff that's
any good and listening to their paper is
is their paper any good well that's
another stuff shirt from an elite
University who doesn't actually have
anything to say and it's usually about
half the time right and I do the same
thing by the way with anybody from a
state school or you know a smaller
private school you know half of them are
full of crap half of marked you don't
want to be what you call a respecter of
persons you know you want to evaluate
these things one at a time so I don't
know anything about that
um a right let's see here
by our again thirteen if Augustine is
the Titan of the West who do you think
would be comparable for Eastern
Orthodoxy I don't know Chrysostom
Gregory of Nyssa I don't know I don't I
don't think that Augustine is the Titan
of the West anyway I think that Ambrose
and Gregory the Great and you know
Jerome and the you know cassia and these
people are important I know I don't buy
into their like the big man theory of
history for intellectual history anymore
thank you for political history you know
Augustine is important but I don't know
that he's like you know the type
that sort of thing ah let's see what
else else do we have here let's scroll
down a bit a lot of back and forth here
Diego Tinoco are you a feminist yeah I
guess you know it depends on the
definition of feminism that you give if
you have something that where it's about
equality and not just merely equality of
opportunity but generating the
possibility for opportunities with say
Mary Wollstonecraft was was charting out
then yeah I'm a feminist and I also you
know I also think that we have some
systemic imbalances when it comes to
safety security you know
treatment I mean I know for example this
is completely stupid stuff that I'm
gonna get better
evaluations than my female colleagues
not because I'm necessarily a better
teacher but because there's an imbalance
female professors get worse evaluations
in general when they do exactly the same
things so you know there's there's
there's a lot of things where I'm like
yeah I'm into that
and some of it stems from the you know
the same same reason I mean I'm an
anti-racist right I believe in justice
and I think there's one human race and I
think that's we should make it possible
for as many people as possible to fully
develop themselves regardless of where
they came from
or you know what what sex or gender or
orientation or national background or
race or linguistic group or you know
pick whatever you want I'm I'm you know
I think that those those sort of
arbitrary distinctions shouldn't be
what's determining how we how we treat
people there's you know there's going to
be great people and there's gonna be
complete [ __ ] among any group that
you pick and so I'd like people to be
treated like Martin Luther King says
based on the content of their character
so I think that makes me a feminist of
sorts I don't buy into the like
everything is patriarchy you know sort
of sort of like excessive stuff
but I think there's a lot to be done in
the present circumstances so you know
and I you know for example I'm I think
abortion is a bad thing in general but I
also look at like the recent laws that
have been passed down in the south that
are clearly just purely misogynist
political posturing and I'm like man I
am almost like tempted to be on the
other side you know so there's a lot to
be a lot to be said about that I don't
talk about it myself as a feminist
because frankly you know I've got a bad
taste in my mouth from going all the way
back to the 90s of all these guys who'd
posture as feminists who definitely
weren't because I treated women like
crap you know but I think about the
world that I you know see ahead of me
and do I want equal opportunities for my
daughter
hell yeah and you know do I want her to
be or my female students in my classes
do I want them to be able to feel as
safe walking on campus or walking down
the street or going out on a date as my
my male students of course you know and
are there real-life obstacles to that
yeah it's not generated by every single
man or all culture or anything like that
but there's definitely some stuff to
call out so yeah
Douglas Struthers should we nationalize
the banking system I guess it depends on
what you mean by nationalize I'm really
attracted to the idea of having a
european-style post office that allows
banking for for the poor and middle
class if that's what you call
nationalizing it sure do you mean like
should we nationalize the companies that
are out there and say hey we're taking
you over Chase Bank I don't know that
I'd be for that I'd have to look at that
a bit more Caesar Augustus who is the
most underrated philosopher in your
opinion that more people should read
right now I would say Cicero there's
still this
prevalent conception that Cicero was
just kind of a derivative thinker now
he's doing some pretty amazing stuff oh
it's already 132 and I have to get to
walking the dog and get back to grading
so I'm gonna have to cut this short let
me see if there's anything I can go out
on real quick to do okay a lot of
back-and-forth chatting in there let's
see here
why there's a ton of stuff here they're
skipping around all over the place as
well god there's a lot of back and forth
between all of you discussing each other
oh here's a good one
this from Alex Jensen any thoughts on
the American pragmatist tradition so I
went to a university for my graduate
school where it's one of the very few
ones in America ironically where there
were a lot of Representatives of the
classical American pragmatist tradition
and American philosophy more broadly
which includes the transcendentalists
and and you know the Jonathan Edwards
and people like that as well so the
American pragmatist tradition I really
like William James and I really like
Josiah Royce and Charles Sanders purse I
think they have a lot of interesting
things to contribute well worth studying
I'm not as big of a fan of John Dewey in
part because I had so much Dewey shoved
down my throat when I was in graduate
school mostly of my people who I
considered to be at best second-rate you
know thinkers I even even worked for the
the Dewey Center for a semester doing
research for them but you know there's
some things that are worth checking out
in in Dewey and you know there's other
pragmatists who aren't quite as well
known I think it's it's uh it's one of
those sort of things where I wouldn't
ever become a pragmatist but I think
that as an eclectic there are some
things that I could take from them that
I really like you know I'm we mentioned
like talking about William James essay
the will to believe I think that's great
stuff put that together with the paschal
who he's referencing and some other
thing
so you know and you get you get some
really cool stuff so well worth reading
I would stick with you know the the big
three early ones
Royce James and purse and then leave the
Dewey for later if you're really
interested in that sort of thing but
it's it's it's worth stuff that's worth
digging into then again so is the
transcendentalist tradition so is
Jonathan Edwards there's some really
great American philosophers out there so
all right I'm gonna leave you on that I
gotta go walk the dog before I got to do
you had another thing and yet another
thing and yet another thing thanks for
all of the questions I'm sorry for the
ones that I wasn't able to get to but
you know how it goes with these sorts of
events and I will see you at some of our
like philosophy pop ups and other online
events including the remember the
aristotle self-directed study tips and
things like that coming up next weekend
which I still have to shoot by the way
so see all of you in the ether somewhere
and have a great morning or evening or
whatever it is where you happen to be